i like to imagine eminem is his internal
monologue is he's british when he does
that and he's mind-blowing like oh
it's you
it's like
our phones when we charge them are
tethered to us
and we can't break it
like when you have like a you know let's
go to commercial
i don't know what you're talking about
jim did you know what anyone was talking
about like man i'm on two hours of sleep
yeah that was
travis
did you feel it as you're doing it like
how do i get out of this i'm about to be
me
there's nothing worse than committing to
a character for a moment and it's
getting a zero then you have to put your
arms back down and come out of it oh
yeah yeah he was fred durst for a second
there what do i do with this hand that's
in the air everybody knows what i just
tried to do oh boy
i am sweating
physically
does it does it help that jim and i are
bringing more attention to it or hurt
but no i definitely understand it i get
it
did you know what he was doing when he
did i didn't know i didn't know i still
don't know what he was doing either um
[Music]
[Laughter]
physically sweating yeah
because he said he turns british and
he's talking about like the phones
tethered but i didn't like have you ever
done have you ever done that thing where
like
you you try to sound mind-blowing as
like a british person like
like well they call it black mirror
because when you look at your phone you
see yourself in darkness
i don't know
why
i mean
like it's like you never do that
you pretend like you're a british person
why would like a mind-blowing revelation
no is that a thing
i do it
yeah but it's like such a dumb thing but
like
it's like when you reveal something
that's so obvious
to a british person no no but you do it
in a british voice to make it sound like
even more like intelligent mind-blowing
well i didn't know that's why they
called it black mirror that's actually
interesting i actually didn't either to
tell you the truth i had no no i didn't
know i had no idea yeah
it's like
i thought it was just a dark reflection
like
which which it is in it
nope when you think when you think
they're yes ending me and you realize
it's sabotage
i gotta take a walk
yeah no i don't know
i didn't
like i don't know why a
british voice being mind blown is
different
like like if you say obvious stuff in a
british voice it's funny to me if you're
like you know i learned in the pandemic
people aren't afraid of dying
i think they're afraid a living
right
funny to you
[Laughter]
oh my god have you found have you found
that it's funny to other people or my
girlfriend likes it
i think carmelo would just be a nice
you don't think ian's girlfriend really
thinks that that's that funny she
couldn't
because it's not right no
you'll notice too every time you do it
and she'll smile you'll notice her eyes
go right to the door she's like i just i
why am i here oh my god oh god i'm
seeing stars you gotta go home and ask
her not in that room you're not
you gotta go home and ask her why would
you sabotage me like that you said that
was funny that's
none of the guys
you kissed me on the phone and said do
the british voice baby
the guys were just confused by it dude
but no the way you tied it in at least
made sense it's like it does sound
smarter when a british guy yeah it is
different yeah
thank you a regular guy having a
revelation is not i think he feels
smarter when a british guy is having one
yes yeah yeah and it's and then yeah and
it makes
it makes it seem less
obvious right like it's almost like the
british guy is having it's like an
intellectual pursuit that the british
guy is figuring out something that we
already knew yes yeah like if russell
brand said it you'd be like whoa
like how would he say it but if joe
rogan said it you'd be like no
right
if he said what if russell brown was
like um
was like uh you know like um
it's like when we go outside
we put on our clothes
and we wear a mask
but is it physical or are we protecting
ourselves from something else
we're all
i wear emotional man
i was wearing emotional earplugs
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my god
yeah yeah
it's weird it's like when you do
something
if something bombs it's very funny
because there's the moment you have to
come it's like especially if you're on
stage and there's a physicality if you
do something physically
up the mic stand and you're like then
you're going to throw it and no one's
laughing because then you have to go
that moment of putting it back down
you're admitting defeat right yes like
you have to in the british character
uh-huh which is still a little confusing
as to where he came from
uh
you have to figure out like how do i how
do i win them back over
uh-huh as this character
that has not only confused them but
really
dissuaded them from being on my side at
all it's it's like it's like you're
sabotaging me
by making me go forward with it but am i
in on the bet
and being bad on purpose
now
no
i didn't even think that last thing was
gonna work
and also you fell into your sopranos
character for a second you went
pointless
and
for the record jim
yeah
was ian being bad on purpose
um in no way shape or form no he was uh
taking a swing at us we all do we take a
swing sometimes and it's just we fell it
off yeah
yeah because ian has some tired manic
energy which i kind of like i'm so tired
and what's wrong with your palms are
they getting sweaty
my arms are heavy
my palms are sweating
i mean you're feeling everything huh
yeah i mean i can have mom's spaghetti
i uh but it's like
i'm sorry are you really eating mom's
spaghetti
in it
in it
or we all have more spaghetti in us
the memory of what mom has made us and
who we are
pasta sauce
on a collective sleeve
nervousness
is it working for you jim
not for you
[Music]
it's also one of the worst accents it's
horrible it's not good isn't it
it's very british
it's horrible it's not now uni
i need to go back to uni for it
it's not good and i should tell my
voiceover agent to stop sending me
english accent
auditions
like
there were multiple times where i
thought he had uh
a punchline no i i thought he'd given up
on the bit and wasn't doing the accent
anymore i was doing a different accent
or just not doing an accent at all and
then i realized oh he's still doing the
accent
just because it wasn't
great
you know so that means he's in on it
in it
no
i don't think so
i don't uh
i mean you're aware of what it's become
but to say you're in on it would credit
yourself for like oh i'm gonna bring
this bad bit to the show on purpose
yeah but that's not how it played out in
your head
but it's like
it's like it
it's changed
to now i'm in on it and it's like we all
change
it
we all evolving
no it's beyond the point of being able
to take ownership yeah no
he's you know what he's trying to do jim
yep he's trying to fred durst his way
out of this
he's trying to be like no i'm gonna
acknowledge i'm going to see in this
what you see in it and we're all going
to enjoy it together but yeah it's still
p i mean
you're weirding people out travis's wife
texted travis concerned for you i think
really
really when it comes down to i'm just
trying to roll and roll and roll through
it
i mean some of these words you can't say
with a british accent i don't know why
you're trying
don't look at me
that's the best advice travis has ever
given
[Laughter]
hey we'll be back at this commercial
break
mike my tone how's this all playing in
there
troy's terrified
like we all love ian but we're worried
you're gonna come home and you're just
gonna find
the furniture gone
[Laughter]
there's one cat left
oh [ __ ] oh i'm crying
[Laughter]
jesus christ
well
can't salvage it you know there's
nothing sadder than the tears of a clown
[Music]
because it's like the clown's supposed
to make you laugh
then when the clown cries
you're sad
the clown not doing his job
part of me feels like
because it's this is a bit ian does you
know like in his house like this is his
bit
yeah
and i feel like there is still a part of
him that wants to bring us around on the
bit it'll happen
but like like you guys just don't get it
no i actually like
look at it
it's i'm turned off by it like yeah it's
disconcerting i'm
it's i'm
he is trying to salvage it but
it's
it's as bad as anything i've heard yeah
ever
yeah yeah
if i just figure out a way to do it
[Laughter]
yeah
or it's almost like it's one of those
rare bits where it's like
now that we've all acknowledged and
laughed at how bad it is
i'm gonna do it again yes and we can all
laugh together at how bad it is yeah but
then you do it again and we all go
it just brings back the initial
kind of discontent well it's like life
is cyclical isn't it
[Laughter]
it's like like a clock
it all goes round
like a clock i wish it would stop
i wish it was like a clock attached to a
bomb
wish somebody would shoot me from a
clock tower